BUT I'D LIKE TO GET THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STARTED -- SO WE
WILL GO BY THE THE FILE ORDER OF
TIME THE FIRST ONE WILL BE.
FROM -- MEMBER.
BOEHNER HARBOR US BURNER BURNER
ALRIGHT.
YOUR PERCENT DEAN BILL AB.
FOR SIXTY SEVEN ARE YOU HAVE
WITNESSES.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING TODAY MY NAME IS
TASHA BOERNER HORVATH AND I AM
PRESENTING AB. FOR SIXTY SEVEN
TO REQUIRE EQUAL PRIVATE PAY A
PRICE.
A PRICE TO PAY FOR BOTH MEN AND
WOMEN ATHLETES WHEN COMPETING ON
IN STATE PROPERTIES FOR
RECREATION -- I THINK ONE OF THE
MOST POWERFUL ASPECTS OF AB FOR
SIXTY SEVEN IS.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT ON OUR
PUBLIC LANDS THEY REFLECT THE
VALUES OF OUR STATE AND OUR
VALUES OF OUR STATE OUR QUALITY
AND EQUITY -- ONE OF THE THINGS
WE'VE SEEN AND AND THE SPORTS
WORLD ESPECIALLY THE INDEPENDENT
NONTRADITIONAL SPORTS.
IS THAT WOMEN ARE PAID
SUBSTANTIALLY LESS THAN MEN
ACROSS THE BOARD AND IN --
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE WAS --
VERY -- IMPORTANT STATE LANDS
COMMISSION DECISION THAT
REQUIRED THE MAVERICKS SURF
CONTEST -- TO REQUIRE PAY EQUITY
FOR MALE AND FEMALE THE
CHAMPIONS AND THIS WAS A GAME
CHANGER SO OUR BILL IS ELOQUENT
IN ITS SIMPLICITY.
IT SAYS IF YOU ARE GOING TO BE
GIVEN A LAND USE PERMIT OR A
LAND LEASE YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE
PAY EQUITY FOR MEN AND WOMEN
DIVISIONS.
AND THAT IS SO SIMPLE AND IT IS
SO ELOQUENT AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE LOOK
THAT WE CODIFY THIS DECISION.
INTO STATE LAW BECAUSE THIS WILL
AFFECT NOT ONLY THE SURFING
WORLD BUT IN THE SKATEBOARDING
WORLD IN THE IRON MAN'S IN
TRIATHLONS AND GROWING AND
SWIMMING.
ON STATE LANDS.
AND WHEN WE LOOK AT IT I THINK
OUR ALL THE LITTLE GIRLS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA NEED TO LOOK
TO THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS I
KNOW THAT WE HAVE THEIR BACKS.
THAT WE ARE FIGHTING FOR
EQUALITY EQUITY IN ALL FORMS AND
I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE THAT.
THESE ATHLETES COMPETE ON OUR
STATE LANDS THIS IS WHERE THEY
WORK THIS IS WHERE THEY COMPETE
RESERVOIR PERFORM THERE'S WHERE
COMPENSATED.
AND NO OTHER SPACE WILL WE EVER
ALLOW.
PAY IN EQUITY AND SO THIS BILL
CODIFIES A VERY SIMPLE PRINCIPLE.
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
AND I'M SO THRILLED TODAY TO
HAVE TWO AMAZING WITNESSES.
FIRST WE HAVE COREY SHOE MARKER.
CORY IS NOT ONLY A COUNCIL
MEMBER AND MY DISTRICT IN
CARLSBAD -- SHE IS A THREE TIME
WOMEN LONGBOARD SURF CHAMPION
WORLD SURF CHAMPION AND THE
FIRST OPENLY GAY WORLD SURF
CHAMPION.
AND I'M SO PROUD TO HAVE HER
ACCOUNT YET SHE DOES WORK PART
TIME IN MY DISTRICT SHE IS HERE
ON HER OWN MONEY SHE IS HERE ON
HER OWN TIME SHE TOOK TODAY OFF --
TO BE HERE AND I'M SO HONOR
BECAUSE IN IN OCTOBER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THIS BEFORE I WAS ELECTED
THE SYMBOL ASSEMBLY.
WE WERE TALKING ABOUT WHAT THIS
MEANS FOR QUALITY IN CALIFORNIA
AND IS WHEN I DECIDED THIS WOULD
BE THE FIRST BILL I INTRODUCED
IN THE ASSEMBLY -- I ALSO HAVE
WITH ME -- CAM WOOZY WHO IS A
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETE ADVOCATE
AND DIRECTOR OF DEVELOPMENT FOR
SKATE LIKE A GIRL SERVICES GO
BEARISH AS MANY CREDENTIALS THAT
SHE'LL TELL US ABOUT -- I AM SO
HONORED TO BE HERE AMONG THE
PRESENCE OF THESE WOMEN WHO HAVE
PAVE THE WAY FOR A BETTER FUTURE
FOR ALL OF OUR CHILDREN'S ALL
TURNED OVER TO QUESTIONS.
THANKS MUCH SIMPLY MEMBER --
VERY PLEASED TO BE HERE IN FRONT
OF YOU THIS MORNING FOR ME -- I
STARTED SURFING WHEN I WAS EIGHT
YEARS OLD SORRY WHEN I WAS FIVE
YEARS OLD I STARTED COMPETING
WHEN I WAS EIGHT YEARS OLD.
AND WOMEN'S ONLY SURF LEAGUE --
AND OVER THE LAST THIRTY TWO
YEARS I CAN TELL YOU THAT THIS
IS A REALLY -- UGH.
PINNACLE MOMENT FOR A LOT OF THE
WORK THAT HAS GONE ON AND THAT
HAVE BEEN A PART OF SPECIFICALLY
WITHIN THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS.
SO HAVING COMPETED SINCE I WAS
EIGHT YEARS OLD -- AND THEN VERY
SPECIFICALLY WORKING ON WOMEN'S
EQUITY WITHIN THE SPORT OF
SURFING.
OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS
SPECIFICALLY I CAN TELL YOU THAT
SOME OF THE EXPERIENCES THAT I
HAD.
A DESPITE HAVING EQUAL ACCESS TO
SERVING SPACES -- WAS DIRECTLY
LINKED TO NOT HAVING PAY EQUITY --
AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOR
INSTANCE MALE ATHLETES BEING
GIVEN SALARIES UPWARDS OF A
MILLION DOLLARS VERSUS A FEMALE
ATHLETE SITTING AT ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
SO THE DISPARITIES MASSIVE --%
THIS BILL -- IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT STEP MOVING FOR TO
ACHIEVING WHAT WE NEED IN IN THE
REALM OF SPORTS.
AND HAVING -- HAVING DONE THE
WORK OF NOT ONLY SITUATIONAL AS
AN ADVOCATE AND AN ATHLETE BUT
ALSO ACADEMICIN EMERGING
CRITICAL SIR STUDIES AND BEING A
PRINCIPAL THEORIST OF SIR
FEMINISM -- WHICH IS A AN
INVITING EMBEDDED NOMADIC SOCIO
POLITICAL INTERVENTION SITUATED
AT THE NEXUS OF SPORT
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AS THIS IS
EMERGING -- THIS WORK --
ACTUALLY PROVIDES REALLY
INTERESTING POLITICAL
OPPORTUNITIES I'M SITTING HERE
IS AN EXAMPLE OF THAT A THREE
TIME WOMEN'S WORLD SURFING
CHAMPION AS A UP THAT COUNCIL
MEMBER AND BEING ABLE TO FOCUS
ON THINGS LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE OF
IT SIGNIFICANT -- THESE EMBEDDED
POLITICAL -- SUBJECTIVITY IS
THAT CAN BE CREATED THROUGH
SPORT -- WE GIVE -- WOMEN GIRLS
THE OPPORTUNITY AND SUCH ONE
LOOP BACK AROUND AND AND SAY
THAT -- SERVING BECAME THE FIRST
US BASED SPORTS LEAGUE TO
ACHIEVE PRIZE MONEY EQUITY.
THIS PAST YEAR.
THE FIRST WOMAN TO RECEIVE EQUAL
PRIZE MONEY ON THE TOUR HAPPENED.
THREE DAYS AGO.
SO FOR THE VERY FIRST TIME A
FEMALE ATHLETE FEMALE
PROFESSIONAL SURFING ATHLETE WAS
ABLE -- TO WALK AWAY WITH A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST AS
HER MALE HERE WHERE IS
PREVIOUSLY SHE MIGHT WALK AWAY
WITH A FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO I JUST ABOUT HALF AND WOMEN
IN EVERY SPORT EVERY LEVEL IN
EVERY EVERY SPORT AT EVERY LEVEL
DESERVE TO KNOW EXACTLY HOW IT
FEELS. TO SEE THIS MOMENT OF
TRUE EMPOWERMENT HAPPEN -- FOR
ONE'S COLLEAGUES AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT ONE SPORTS ABOUT ALL
SPORTS -- EMPOWERING NEXT
GENERATION OF OUR LEADERS KNEW
POLITICAL ALLIES WHO UNDERSTAND
THAT FALLING DOWN IS JUST ONE
STEP IN RISING UP.
IS EXACTLY WHAT THIS BILL IS
ABOUT AND I WOULD URGE A YES AND
I VOTE OF THIS BILL AS IT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED TO THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU.
HI.
MY NAME IS KIM -- THREE ZERO I
AM ACTUALLY A PRODUCT OF TITLE
NINE GREW UP PLAYING SPORTS --
TODAY I AM A SKATEBOARDER AN
ENTREPRENEUR AND COMMUNITY
LEADER -- I AM THE CO FOUNDER
AND PARTNER OF THE W. SAY THE
WOMEN SKATEBOARDING ALLIANCE WE
ARE A GLOBAL ADVOCACY.
CONSULTING AND SPUR ORGANIZING
AGENCY WE REPRESENT REPRESENT
AMATEUR AND PROFESSIONAL FEMALE
SKATEBOARDERS AROUND THE WORLD --
OVER THE PAST DECADE OUR WORK
HAS INCREASED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
WOMEN TO PRESERVE PURSUE CAREERS.
AS PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES IN
SKATEBOARDING -- SUCH THAT THAT
IS HAPPENING TODAY I ALSO DIRECT
FIVE ONE C. THREE CALLED SCALE
LIKE A GIRL WITH A CHAPTER IN
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
WE PROVIDE FREE ACCESSIBLE
PROGRAMS AT SKATE PARKS PUBLIC
SKATEPARKS AS WELL SCHOOLS.
AND OUR MISSION IS TO CREATE
EQUITY INCLUSIVITY FOUR PEOPLE
HAVE WHO HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED IN SKATEBOARDING
CULTURE AS WELL AS IN SOCIETY
INCLUDING.
YOU UNDERSERVED YOUTH WOMEN
CLEAR TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING PEOPLE -- THEIR
SKATEBOARDING WERE ABLE TO
PROMOTE SOCIAL JUSTICE
LEADERSHIP AND CONFIDENCE.
AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
ADVISORY BOARD AT THE CENTER FOR
SPORTS AND SOCIAL JUSTICE THAT
HEALTH CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY EAST BAY.
I'M IN THROUGH EDUCATION OR
RESEARCH -- WERE REALLY
COMMITTED TO TRANSFORMING
ORGANIZED SPORTS IN OUR SPORTS
CULTURE IN AMERICA BY EXAMINING
RACE CLASS GENDER DISABILITY AND
SEXUALITY -- WITH VERY FEW
BARRIERS TO ENTRY AND HIGH
ACCESSIBILITY RATE SKATEBOARDING
IS ACTUALLY SOCIAL MOVEMENT
EXPLODING AROUND THE WORLD --
IT'S ONE OF THE FEW SPORTS WHERE
PARTICIPANTS CAN LEARN AND
ENGAGE IN PUBLIC SPACE
INTERSECTING.
AGE CLASS RACE AND GENDER AND
SKATEBOARDING RELEASE ABLE TO
TEACH SELF ADVOCACY SELF
EXPRESSION AND COMMUNITY
BUILDING -- SKATEBOARDS OF
ACTUALLY BECOME A RADICAL
VEHICLE FOR TRANSFORMATION FOR
MANY MARGINALIZED GROUPS OF
PEOPLE INCLUDING WOMEN -- FOR ME
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
DISTINGUISH EQUITY VERSUS A
QUALITY HISTORICALLY IN
SKATEBOARDING WOMEN HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED OBJECTIFIED AND IN
TREATED UNEQUALLY.
AND FOR ME HAVING SPENT THE PAST
DECADE REALLY ELEVATING WOMEN I
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
SPACE FOR WOMEN ONLY EVENTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND BROWN'S.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THESE
GIRLS AND WOMEN'S EXPERIENCE.
BEING HEARD PRIORITIZE AND
SPOTLIGHTED -- AND YOU KNOW I BY
SUPPORT AB FOUR SIX SEVEN THEY
SEE THE PAY EQUITY IS ONE OF THE
WAYS TO TRULY ACHIEVE GENDER
EQUALITY.
AND I JUST WILL GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE -- BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN X. GAMES THIS WHICH IS ONE
OF THE LARGEST -- PROFESSIONAL
COMPETITIONS FOR SKATEBOARDING
THE FIRST PLACE -- FEMALE --
WINNER -- TO COME TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND HER MALE
COUNTERPARTS ACCOUNT FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THERE'S A BIG
GAP THERE AND THROUGH THE WORK
OF THE ALLIANCE A WOMAN
SKATEBOARDING ALLIANCE -- IN
JUST A FEW YEARS THEY WERE WE
WERE ABLE TO ACHIEVE -- PAY
EQUITY IN ALL OF AXIOMS EVERY
SPORT EVERY CATEGORY -- AND THAT
REALLY HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE IN
KNOW WHAT'S AVAILABLE FOR GIRLS
AND WOMEN TODAY TO ACTUALLY MAKE
A CAREER.
OUT OF BEING A PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETE -- SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
GREAT THANK YOU KIMBERLY THE
LAST TIME I SAW YOU YOU WERE
JUST A POPULAR.
YOUR SUCH A VERY BUT C<c.cyan>G</c>
ACCOMPLISH A WOMAN SO BEFORE WE
ARE HERE TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
I LIKE TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
AND MADONNA SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
KANSEN CHU -- KANSEN CHU HERE.
DE [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI.
CHOI HERE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN HERE COME LONGER DATA
[inaudible]
THIS AREA.
HIS HEARING HERE.
WE HAVE A CAR SO WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM AND IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF AB FOR SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE
COME. FOR FOR A GAY AS YOU HARM
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SHERRI PEMBERTON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE REYES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WOULD INSIST IN
SUPPORT.
I I DON'T SEE ANY.
OPPOSITION BUT I HAVE TO ASK THE
QUESTION ANYWAY OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME.
p[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THANKS.
FOR SO I'D LIK TO START BY
HANDING OUT THIS INFORMATION
OKAY.
YOU HAVE A HANDED OUT. TO THIS
THE SERGEANT WILL WELL WILL PASS
THE MALL.
WELL AFTER YOU'VE DONE.
AND THEN IF YOU COULD PLEASE SET
UP PLEASE.
MATERIAL IN THERE THAT I'D LIKE
TO POINT TO DURING MY COMMENTS
SO WHAT WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE.
JODY ONE DID TO POTTER THEM NOW
THAT'S FINE BUT IT COULD BE A
BIG DISTRACTION A MOVIE READING
YOUR MATERIAL INSTEAD OF
LISTENING TO YOURSELF.
IS YOUR CALL THE WALLET HOUSE AT
ALL.
WE'LL LOOK INTO IT THANK YOU.
THE LETTER PERCENT.
NO LETTER PERFECT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRPERSON CHIU
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
SABRINA BRENNAN PRESIDENT OF THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY HARBOR
COMMISSION.
AND CO FOUNDER OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR EQUITY IN WOMEN SURFING.
THANK YOU FOR THIS IMPORTANT
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING I AWOKE
TO A REOCCURRING NIGHTMARE ABOUT
GENDER BASED DISCRIMINATION IN
THE WORKPLACE.
UNFAIR BUSINESS PRACTICES AND
THE SYSTEMATIC EXCLUSION OF
WOMEN PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES FROM
COMPETITIONS.
TODAY I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
SAN MATEO COUNTY HARPER DISTRICT.
WE ISSUE A SPECIAL USE PERMIT
FOR THE ICONIC MAVERICKS
CHALLENGE BIG WAVE SURF
COMPETITION.
HELD NEAR HALF MOON BAY.
MAVERICKS WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT AND THE
CONTEST IS INTERNATIONALLY KNOWN
FOR PRODUCING THIRTY TO SIXTY
FOOT WAVES.
AND IT'S EVENT PROMOTERS ARE
NOTORIOUS FOR GENDER BASED
DISCRIMINATION.
THE FIRST MEMBERS COMPETITION
WAS TITLED MAN WHO RIDE
MOUNTAINS NOW TWO DECADES LATER
WOMEN BIG WAVE SURFERS HAVE
STILL NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
COMPETE.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO ACHIEVE EQUAL
PAY AN ATHLETIC COMPETITION THAT
EXCLUDE WOMEN.
PLEASE READ THE MARCH TWENTY
NINTH LETTER FROM THE HARBOR
COMMISSION WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT AB FOR SIX SEVEN BE
AMENDED TO PROTECT ATHLETES FROM
GENDER BASED DISCRIMINATION.
CONSISTENT WITH THE HONOREE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT WE URGE YOU TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS ABOUT
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES PLEASE
CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE IN AB.
FOUR SIX SEVEN THAT ENCOURAGES
AND INCENTIVIZE IS EVENT
BUSINESSES PROMOTERS AND
ATHLETIC ORGANIZATIONS TO
EXCLUDE FEMALE CATEGORIES FROM
ATHLETIC COMPETITIONS.
IN AN EFFORT TO THE WORK EQUAL
PAY REQUIREMENTS PLEASE REQUIRE
THE FOLLOWING A FEMALE CATEGORY
AND A MALE CATEGORY FOR ALL
ATHLETIC COMPETITIONS HELD ON
CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS.
EQUAL PRIZE MONEY.
CATEGORY WINNERS RECEIVING THE
EXACT SAME PRICE AMOUNT.
NO TOTAL PURSE FORMULA APPLIED.
EQUAL LOGISTICAL SUPPORT FOR ALL
CATEGORIES INCLUDING TRAVEL
RELATED EXPENSES AIRFARE HOTEL
ETCETERA.
EQUAL EQUIPMENT FOR ALL
CATEGORIES MAVERICKS IS NOT THE
ONLY PROFESSIONAL ATHLETIC
COMPETITION WITH THE HISTORY OF
GENDER BASED DISCRIMINATION.
LAST MONTH WOMEN WERE EXCLUDED
FROM COMPETING IN HUNTINGTON
BEACH AT THE JACKS.
SURFBOARDS PRO A WORLD SURF
LEAGUE FIFTEEN HUNDRED
QUALIFYING SERIES OF THAT.
THAT AWARDS PRIZE MONEY AND
POINTS WOMEN PRO SURFERS ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE SCARCITY OF
QUALIFYING EVENTS IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS INEQUITY SIGNIFICANTLY
LIMITS THEIR OPPORTUNITIES TO
MAKE A LIVING AS PRO ATHLETES.
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF EVENTS
AND AWARDS FOR WOMEN AS WELL AS
OFFERING EQUAL PRIZE MONEY IS
THE ONLY WAY TO ACHIEVE
MEANINGFUL EQUITY IN COMPETITIVE
SPORTS.
EQUAL PAY IS ONLY PART OF THE
PROBLEM PLEASE REQUIRE THAT ALL
STATE AGENCY PERMITS AND LEASES
PROHIBIT DISCRIMINATION.
PLEASE AMEND AB FOUR SIX SEVEN
TWO REQUIRED BUSINESSES AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT MANAGE.
AND PROMOTE ATHLETIC
COMPETITIONS ON CALIFORNIA STATE
LANDS COMPLY WITH THE UN RESELL
RIGHTS ACT.
UNFAIR BUSINESS PRACTICES
PREVENT WOMEN PROFESSIONAL
SURFERS FROM UTILIZING PUBLIC
RESOURCES AND COASTAL ACCESS
PLEASE ACT TO PROHIBIT GENDER
BASED DISCRIMINATION PLEASE
ENSURE THAT AB FOR SIX SEVEN
PROVIDES.
THE OVERSIGHT NECESSARY TO STOP
DECADES OF GENDER BASED
DISCRIMINATION.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION PLEASE
COME [inaudible]
FOR SURE.
DO YOU HOW DO.
WHAT WE HEARD THE OUT DATED THE
REMAINING ON?
THE POSITION IS.
HELLO THIS IS IT WHOA WHOA WHOA.
OPPOSITION LOW THIS FINISH THIS
IS SAM MY POSITION IS SUPPORT IF
AMENDED AND WE DIDN'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT WASN'T CALLED
OUT -- I'M SEEING A NOD FROM
MISS MITCHELL SO IF YOU'LL ALLOW
ME I'D LIKE TO OFFER A POSITION
OF SUPPORT IF AMENDED OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- GOOD
MORNING CHAIRPERSON CHEWING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
KAREN TIENEN.
I'M THE FOUNDING COUNSEL FOR THE
COMMITTEE OF IT ON FOR EQUITY
AND WOMEN'S SURFING -- BRIEFLY I
HAVE -- TWO QUICK POINTS TO MAKE --
WITH REGARD TO THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION -- AND MAVERICKS I
WAS THE PERSON THAT DRAFTED THAT
LEAST LANGUAGE THE NON
DISCRIMINATORY LANGUAGE.
I DO CONSIDER MYSELF A VERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE PERSON ABOUT THAT
ISSUE.
AND THAT IS ONE REASON WHY I
SUPPORT IF AMENDED.
AND SECONDLY I WOULD LIKE TO
POINT OUT THAT THE FIRST TIME A
WOMAN SURFER RECEIVED EQUAL PAY
WAS IN NOVEMBER.
AT THE PALEY CHALLENGE IN HAWAII --
BASED UPON -- OUR WORK FROM THE
COMMITTEE WITH THE WORLD SURF
LEAGUE.
AND PART OF HOW THE COMMITTEE
FOR EQUITY IN WOMEN SURFING WAS
ABLE -- TO LEVERAGE THE WORLD
SURF LEAGUE INTO REQUIRING PAY
EQUITY.
WAS THROUGH A TWO PRONG.
ANALYSIS.
OF ACCESS AND PAY PARITY WE
DEMANDED ACCESS FOR THE WOMEN
WHICH IS WHY WE WANT AND AMENDED
AB FOUR SIX SEVEN TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE UNREST CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT.
BY INCORPORATING A CONCISE
REFERENCE TO THE UNREST CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION MY NAME IS SOUL AND
I AM A SUPPORT IF AMENDED.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
THANK YOU WOULD YOU USUALLY
ALLOWED TO WITNESSES AND
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES SO I WOULD
JUST PLEASE ASK YOU TO STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION OF COURSE.
I AM IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR SIX
SEVEN IF AMENDED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER -- WITNESSES.
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE COME
FORWARD AND STATE YOUR NAME AND
A FULL AFFILIATION.
NO ONE SORRY WOULD WE HAVE WERE
ONLY ALLOWED -- TO OF WITNESSES
TO TESTIFY [inaudible]
HELLO.
MY NAME IS PRINTER I'M A CIVIL
RIGHTS ACTIVISTS HAVE BEEN
WATCHING THIS ISSUE FOR QUITE
SOME TIME I JUST WANTED TO
MENTION I ALSO SUPPORT THIS OF
AMENDED AN ASSOCIATE MYSELF.
WITH COMMENTS OF SABRINA BRENNAN
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WELL AT THIS TIME -- JUST OPEN
UP THE DíAS FLOW INTO MEMBERS.
THANK YOU I HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE WITNESS WHO SPOKE IN
OPPOSITION -- SO YOUR OBJECTION
JUST SO I UNDERSTAND IT IS THAT
YOU SUPPORT THE SPIRIT OF THE
BILL BUT YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERY CONTEST HAS A MAN A
MALE AND A FEMALE DIVISION.
SO MY QUESTION IS WHAT ABOUT --
SPORTING EVENTS WERE THEY WOULD
JUST HAVE IT OPEN TO MEN AND
WOMEN IN THE SAME DIVISION WOULD
THAT BE AN OPTION AS WELL --
ACTUALLY. TO CLARIFY I AM ALSO
THE CO FOUNDER OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR EQUITY AND WOMEN SERVING IN
ADDITION TO BEING THE PRESIDENT
OF THE SAN MATEO COUNTY HARBOR
COMMISSION.
AND IT'S KIND OF AN INTERESTING
QUESTION THAT YOU ASKED BECAUSE
THE COMMITTEE FOR EQUITY IN
WOMEN SURFING WHAT WE SUPPORT
SOME WEARING THAT HAT RIGHT NOW.
IS WE SUPPORT THREE CATEGORIES
WE SUPPORT AND MEN'S CATEGORY A
WOMEN'S CATEGORY AND AN OPEN NON
BINARY CATEGORY.
THE HARBOR COMMISSION WHICH IS A
FIVE MEMBER BOARD SUPPORTS AND
MEN'S CATEGORY AND WOMEN'S
CATEGORY BECAUSE THAT'S
CURRENTLY WHAT IS REQUIRED FOR
THE MAVERICKS SURF COMPETITION
AND THAT'S THE EVENT.
THAT WE PERMIT SO.
SLIGHTLY TO SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
POSITIONS LIKE SURFING IS NOT
THE ONLY SPORT THAT COULD BE
HELD IN A PUBLIC LAND SO THAT'S
CORRECT SO IF IF THE BILL WAS
CRAFTED SO THE BILL'S NOT JUST
BEING CRAFTED FIRST FOR SURFING.
SO ASSUMING THAT THERE COULD BE
BECAUSE IS A STATE WIDE THIS
COULD BE ANY PUBLIC LAND IT
MIGHT NOT BE A COASTAL PUBLIC
LAND IT COULD BE COMPLETELY
OTHER SPORTS.
WOULD YOU BE OKAY WITH SOMETHING
WHERE A SPORTING EVENT COULD DO
OF MAN AND MAN AND A WOMAN EVENT
OR JUST AN OPEN EVENT FOR
WHOEVER IT COMPLETELY DEPENDS ON
THAT SPORT SO IN CYCLING I WOULD
SAY ABSOLUTELY NOT THERE NEEDS
TO BE.
A MEN'S DIVISION OR CATEGORY AND
A WOMEN'S CATEGORY OR DIVISION
AND THERE WOULD BE A MEN'S RACE
OR A WOMEN'S RACE OR SUGGEST
THEN THAT THE BILL.
ACTUALLY LIST EVERY ALL THE
DIFFERENT SPORTS AND THEN SAY
WHETHER OR NOT AN OPEN.
CATEGORY WOULD BE PERMISSIBLE
FOR THAT SPORT AS OPPOSED TO A
SEPARATE MEN BECAUSE THERE ARE
SPORTS WHERE WOMEN ACTUALLY WANT
TO COMPETE.
WITH THE MEN IN AN OPEN --
COMPETITION WE DON'T KNOW OF ANY
SPORTS LIKE THAT THAT ARE HELD
ON STATE LANDS IF YOU CAN THINK
OF ONE I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT IT
IS.
I DON'T KNOW THE LIST OF ALL THE
ALL THE SPORTS THAT ARE ON STATE
LANDS BUT I USED TO PLAY.
OUR PROFESSIONAL SPORTS WHERE
THE WOMEN VERY MUCH WANTED TO
THE TIMES PLAY WITH THE MEN HAND
OFF SOMETIMES WHEN ALLOWED TO
WELL IF OUR SPORTS LIKE THAT
THANK YOU I I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING BUT WE HAVE LOOKED AT
WHAT.
THE SPORTS THAT ARE BEING PLAYED
PROFESSIONALLY ON PUBLIC LANDS
AND ON STATE LAND WE HAVEN'T
FOUND ANY WHERE THERE ARE --
LEAKS THAT WANT TO PLAY WITH
BOTH MEN AND WOMEN IN THE SAME
COMPETITIVE CATEGORY SO WE JUST
HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T FOUND THAT.
YEAH BUT AS FAR AS WE'RE
CONCERNED FOR PRO ATHLETES THAT
ARE WOMEN TO BE ABLE TO MAKE IT
FINANCIALLY IN THE WORKPLACE AS
ATHLETES.
THEY ABSOLUTELY CAN'T COMPETE
AGAINST MEN BECAUSE IF THEY DO
THAT THEY WON'T WIN AND THEY
WON'T GET THE PRIZE MONEY THAT
THEY NEED. TO FURTHER THEIR
SPORT THERE'S NO WAY THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO STICK WITH THE SPORT SO
A BOXES GIRLS OUT IT BOXES WOMEN
OUT IF I UNDERSTAND I THINK I
ANSWERED THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A THREE NO ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE DAYS --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
BURN A HARMLESS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH -- I
APPRECIATE THE I I JUST WANT --
TO SET THE RECORD STRAIGHT THAT
MISS BROWN IS HERE WITH A I
BELIEVE SUPPORT WITH AS A IF
AMENDED POSITION NOT IN
OPPOSITION IS THAT CORRECT WE
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO BE SORT
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED BUT WE'VE.
THANK YOU VERY HELPS A LOT OF
THIS LAST NIGHT OUT SO -- I WANT
TO CLARIFY FOR MY COLLEAGUES AND
AND MY CO AUTHORS OF THIS BILL
THIS BILL IS A SINGLE ISSUE BILL
AND IS DOING WITH PAY
COMPENSATION.
WE ARE NOT LOOKING AT INCLUSION
AT THIS TIME AND THIS BILL -- AS
WE KNOW ALL OVER BILLS ARE YOU
SINGLE -- SUBJECT BILLS AND AND
JUST LOOKING AT PAY EQUITY AND
ATHLETIC CONTESTS ON THE STATE
OF LANCE.
SO I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THAT I APPRECIATE THE ADVOCACY
OF THE MANY PEOPLE IN THIS ROOM
WHO SUPPORT THE MOMENTS WE WILL
BE LOOKING FORWARD TO AND AND
TRACKING -- THE DIFFERENT
ATHLETIC CONTESTS I THINK AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
CORRECTLY POINTED OUT THERE ARE
MANY DIFFERENT ATHLETIC CONTEST
THIS AFFECTS NOT JUST SURFING --
AND NOT JUST IN OUR COASTAL
AREAS CYCLING IS A VERY BIG ONE
WHERE WE HAVE A LOT OF
INEQUITIES AND PAY COMPENSATION.
AND WE HAVE TO ALSO REMEMBER
IT'S NOT JUST THE PRO SPORTS IS
ALL THE QUALIFYING MEETS THAT.
LEAD UP TO IT WHERE THIS BILL
WOULD IN FACT AND I THINK THIS
IS THE PLACE WHERE WE START TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND WE SHOW
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT THEIR ELECTED OFFICIALS
HAVE THEIR BACK AND WE WILL MAKE
THIS CHANGE AND WE WILL TRACK
ANYTHING -- FURTHER WE WILL BE
SUBMITTING A COMMENT TO THE
JOURNAL -- WITH THE INTENTION
THAT THIS BILL IS IN NO WAY TO
ELIMINATE ANY -- EXISTING FEMALE
CATEGORIES BECAUSE OF THIS BILL
CENSURE THAT THE RECORD IS
STRAIGHT ON WHAT THE INTENTION
AS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURNER -- HALL
BETS FOR YOUR HARD WORK I I I
LIKE TO SIMPLE BILL.
YOU KNOW THIS BILL DOES ENJOY
AND I RECOMMENDATION FROM THOSE
CHAIR.
AND THINGS WE DON'T HAVE A CLUE
WHAT IT WOULD DO HAVE A QUORUM
BUT WE LOST SOME A MEMBERS HE
ATE YOU.
I HAVE -- YOU'LL YOU'LL ON THE
YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL COMMENT
PLEASE.
YEAH SO -- FIRST OF ALL I WANT
TO COMMEND.
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS ISSUE FORWARD -- IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE IT'S NOT
EASY AND IT'S TIME THAT WE HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION ABOUT
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS AND ABOUT
THE ROLE OF OUR STATE LANDS AND
WHAT WE CAN DO THAT. TO HELP
WITH THE EFFORT OF SUPPORTING
WOMEN SPORTS SO I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
I HAVE I DO HAVE -- THE SAME
CONCERN ABOUT -- PROMOTERS NOT
WANTING.
TO HAVE PAY EQUITY -- AND NOT
WANTING TO HAVE THAT ADDITIONAL
EXPENSE AND CUTTING THE WOMEN'S
EVENTS OUT OF THEIR PROGRAMS.
AND I KNOW THAT THAT'S CERTAINLY
NOT YOUR INTENTION BUT IT COULD
BE AN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
FAR AS I SEE IT AND INTENT
LANGUAGE ISN'T GONNA BE ENOUGH
TO STOP SOMEONE HAS TO THERE HAS
TO BE A STRONGER WAY OF MAKING
SURE THAT THAT'S PROHIBITED.
AND WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
POLICE EVERY EVENT ACROSS THE
STATE IN EVERY -- STATE LAND SO
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW I WOULD LOVE TO SEE YOU
ADDRESS AS YOU MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD -- I DO THINK THAT THERE
SHOULD BE AN OPTION FOR PEOPLE
TO DO THE MIX STANDARD EVENTS IN
CERTAIN SITUATIONS ONE THAT'S
APPROPRIATE I PLAY PROFESSIONAL
SPORTS IN A SPORT WHERE WOMEN DO --
NOW ARE NOW BEGINNING TO PLAY ON
EQUAL FOOTING WITH MEN CERTAINLY
NOT EVERY WOMAN NOT EVERY
CATEGORY BUT WE HAVE SOME WOMEN
THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BREAK
THROUGH AND WANTED TO PLAY WITH
THE MEN AND HISTORICALLY WE'VE
HAD A COUPLE OF WOMEN.
WHO WERE DENIED THE ABILITY TO
DO THAT SO I THINK WE'RE WE
DON'T WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHEN SPORTS CAN BE
INTEGRATED IN THAT WAY THAT WE
DON'T STOP THAT FROM HAPPENING
THAT WE HELP ENCOURAGE THAT?
SO THERE MIGHT BE A WAY OF
WRITING THAT IN WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR CERTAIN AREAS --
BUT AS SOMEONE WHO DID PLAY ON A
PROFESSIONAL LEVEL I ABSOLUTELY
EXPERIENCE -- TO KIND OF THE
SHAME OF THE PAY AND EQUITY.
AND OF ALWAYS BEING KIND OF THE
SECOND CLASS YOU KNOW JUST YOU
KNOW THE KIDS TABLE OF THE SPORT.
IF YOU WILL SO I DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE THE ADVOCATES AND THE
ATHLETES WHO ARE HERE AND I
ANYTIME AN ATHLETE BRINGS OF
FEMINISM FEMINIST CRITICAL
THEORY YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO GIVE
ME A LOT OF PROPS -- THE FIRST
TIME I'VE HEARD THAT SINCE I'VE
BEEN HERE.
AND IT'S IT'S A REFRESHING -- SO --
THANK YOU ALL AND I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY AND I'LL
I'LL MOVE IT.
RAIL ALL SECOND IT.
A GREAT AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND I SECOND THAT ALSO WELL
THANK ALL THE WITNESSES SAYS
HERE.
HAVE A SAFE DRIVE HOME FAMILY.
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
FROM.
BODE GO DO -- OKAY GO TO MY
MODESTO CA TO REPLACE KALRA.
THINGS WOULD YOU HAVE WITH THEM.
KANSEN CHU HI KANSEN CHU ONLINE
DE [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I COME WATER DIVE.
MISS ARIAN.
THIS AREA.
THANK YOU KILEY THOUGH OKAY OLD
PUT THIS BILL ON CALL.
NOON FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS WE
HAVE PROBABLY WHAT TWELVE
COMMITTEE GOING ON RIGHT NOW SO
THERE TO PEOPLE IN AND OUT AND
DEFINITELY LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR THE ABSENT.
MEMBERS [inaudible]
BROTHER CORK.
YOUR BROTHER CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS CAN. THIRTY ONE
THIRTY TWO IF YOU CAN THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FULLER
SHORTS -- AB TEN THIRTY TWO
MAKES A REASONABLE EXPANSION
CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMER PRODUCT
PROTECTIONS REGARDING TICKET
SALES [inaudible]
OFFICE.
OFTEN TICKETS TO POPULAR SHOWS
ARE SNAPPED UP BY ONLINE BOTS.
WHICH THEN RAPIDLY RE LIST THOSE
TICKETS ON REFILL RESALE
PLATFORM SAID INFLATED PRICES.
RECOGNIZING THIS IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN THE LEGISLATURE MADE IT
A CRIME TO USE BOTS TO BUY AND
RESELL TICKETS INVOLVED.
AB TEN THIRTY TWO ADDRESSES A
LOOPHOLE IN EXISTING LAW -- INTO.
UNDER AB TEN THIRTY TWO FIRST
PARTY SERVICES THAT SERVE THE
SAME PURPOSES.
THAT IS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE THE
OFFICIAL SALES PERSON FOR THE
EVENT -- WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
BUY AND SELL TICKETS IN BULK
FOOD WOULD BE ILLEGAL FOR THEM
AS WELL AS FOR THIRD PARTIES.
THE BILL WILL ALSO MAKE CLEAR
WHO WE ARE PRETTY WHO WE ARE
TRYING TO PROTECT WITH THESE
LAWS THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIA.
TENDING SHOWS BASICALLY MY WIFE
WHO LIKES TO ATTEND ROCK
CONCERTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FIHRI VOTE
THIS IS A REAL PROBLEM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES ARE.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE COME.
FOR TRAIN NONE OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
DANCE [inaudible]
SEEN ON BROTHER A COURT WOULD
ELECTRICALS.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS BILL
DOES ENJOY AN AYE RECOMMENDATION.
AND IF I CAN HAVE A MOTION.
AGAIN I HAVE A MOTION
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE SECOND [inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT THEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TEN THIRTY TWO QUIRK.
DO YOU PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON PRIVACY AND PROTECTION KANSEN
CHU I KANSEN CHU EYEING DEEP
[inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI.
CHOI NINE FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
IS THERE IN.
HI.
NAZARIAN I COME LOOK AT THAT HI
[inaudible]
WEARING [inaudible]
WE CORRECT.
OKAY WILL LEAVE IT OPEN THANK
YOU THE ABSENTEE MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- WE HAVE MR
HOLDEN.
AND THE HOUSE.
MISTER BOND --
DAY.
ORANGE JUICE FOR WORKING FOR D. --
THE MEMBERS TO PRESENT A BILL
LIKE -- TO SHE ENJOYED THEM
MOTION O ACCEPT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AND MARIE -- DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MAN AND SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
KANSEN CHU ALL RIGHT KANSEN CHU
ONLINE DE [inaudible]
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI.
CHOI NINE FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE ONLINE IN THIS
AREA.
NAZARIAN HI THANK YOU TO LEAVE
IT OPEN
[inaudible]
ALL AMERICAN
.
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
HOLDEN AND A HOUSE.
IN HIS PRETENDING AB.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE THERE'S
THE HOLDEN FORESHORES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- I LIKE TO THINK YOU
AND APPRECIATE THE ABILITY OF
OPPORTUNITY 2% -- A. B. --
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE WHILE
IMPROVEMENTS OF THE WAY COLLEGE
ATHLETES ARE TREATED HAVE BEEN
MADE OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES.
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN OF THE GOODNESS
OF THE NC TO A HEART.
THAT HAPPENED BECAUSE ATHLETES
IN ADVOCATES FOUGHT FOR FAIRNESS
IN QUESTION A SYSTEM.
THAT IS EXPLOITATIVE.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO GIVE COLLEGE
ATHLETES EVEN MORE TOOLS AND
PROTECTION TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES OR ABUSES THEY MAY
FACE ON CAMPUS.
WE CAN STE CONSTANTLY SEE
EXAMPLES OF COLLEGE STUDENTS AND
ATHLETES DEALING WITH ABUSE.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS
PROBLEMS IN A WAY.
BY EDUCATING AND EQUIPPING.
COLLEGE ATHLETES TO BE EVEN
BETTER ADVOCATES FOR THEMSELVES
AND PROTECTING THEM AS THEY DO
IT.
I REQUIRE SCHOOLS TO INFORM
STUDENTS OF THEIR RIGHTS AND
DOCUMENTATION AND PUBLIC IT
SIGNAGE.
INCLUDING WHO THEY'RE MANDATED
REPORTERS ARE.
IT ALSO PROTECTS STUDENTS BY
PROHIBITING RETALIATION BY
SCHOOLS OF A STUDENT REPORTS
VIOLATIONS OF ABUSE OR
VIOLATIONS OF RIGHTS.
IT ALSO ALLOWS SCHOOLS TO CREATE
A DEGREE COMPLETION FUND WHICH
IS A MECHANISM SCHOOLS CAN
CHOOSE TO CREATE.
AND CHOOSE HOW IT WILL BE USE.
WHAT I COMPLETED?
AT SAN DIEGO STATE THE NC TO A
WAS NOT.
THE BILLION DOLLAR ORGANIZATION
IS TODAY.
NONE THE LESS I HAVE FIRST HAND
EXPERIENCE AND KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE TO BE A COLLEGE ATHLETE.
THESE COLLEGE ATHLETES ARE
PUTTING EVERYTHING ON THE LINE
AND RISKING THEIR BODIES AND FOR
SOME ONE INJURY AWAY FROM LOSING
EVERYTHING.
OTHERS AT RISK OF LOSING ALL FOR
SPEAKING OUT FOR THEIR TEAM OR
ANY ABUSES THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
AS COLLEGE COACHES HAVE THE
POWER TO KEEP YOU ON OR OFF THE
TEAM.
I APPLAUD ALL SCHOOLS ARE DOING
A GOOD WORKER PROTECTING COLLEGE
ATHLETES HEALTH ACADEMIC
PROGRESS AND ECONOMIC FUTURE.
HOWEVER NOT OVER SCHOOL DOES.
AND THIS BILL I BELIEVE WILL
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE SO I RISK
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL -- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
HE'S COME.
FOR GOOD MORNING THIS IS POSH ON
BUT THE UC SINICIZATION ONE
SUPPORT IN CONCERT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SEC.
GOOD MORNING RUN AVAILABLE ON
BEHALF OF STANFORD UNIVERSITY WE
JUST WE HAVE A POSITION I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK
ON THE AMENDMENTS.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE DIRECTION
THE BILL'S GOING IN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- TYLER EIGLER ON
BEHALF THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
JUST ONE ECHO WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR -- AND I APPRECIATE --
THE AMENDMENTS AND I CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
KATHLEEN SORIANO WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE WENT TO A WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION BUT WE DON'T
WANT TO THINK -- THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO WORK ALONG WITH US
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ALEX GRAVES THE
ASSOCIATION DEPEND A CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES -- WE ARE
ECHO THE COMMENTS MY
PREDECESSORS HAVE THANK YOU TO
COMMITTEE THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHORS OFFICE WILL CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE THIS MEANS FORWARD.
GREAT THANK YOU. THREE NO
FURTHER -- PUBLIC -- OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTION FROM THE MEMBERS
AND THE DETAILS.
I MOVE THE BILL'S ELEVEN MOTION
YET.
QUESTION YES PLEASE YEAH SO WE
DO HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND AND SECOND THANK
YOU.
OKAY AS A MINIMUM ORDER ALREADY.
FOR YOU UNDERSTAND A YOUR
CONCERN.
BUT I WONDER IF -- THIS -- STERN
ATHLETE BILLABLE WHITES --
ENCOURAGING TO ADD TO THE
COMPLETION FUND -- ONCE SAID
THIS IS THE ADDED TO IT IS THAT
A JUSTICE EMPEROR OFF PRINCE
SPORES STATE MENTAL WHY IS A
MANDATE. FOR SCHOOL -- SCHOOL --
SO.
TO HAVE THIS -- OF THE BILL --
DESCRIBES THIS COMPLETION FUND
pCAN CHOOSE TO HAVE A FUND.
OR NOT THIS IS A MORE BY
ENCOURAGEMENT.
I SEE OKAY THANK YOU.
RIGHT GRAY AND UNION
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
CENA I'M A MILLISECOND HERE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE HOLDEN.
DO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION KANSEN CHU BY
KANSEN CHU ÁI DE
[inaudible]
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI -- CHOI NINE FRIEDMAN
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I MISS ARIAN.
HI NAZARIAN HI.
ARRAY WILL LEAVE LEAVE THE BILL
OF OPEN FOR THE ABSENTEE MEMBERS.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MISTER
[inaudible]
SHE
THIS CONCORD HAVE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO VOTE ON AB FOR SIXTY
SEVEN THE CALL -- AB
[inaudible]
FOR SIXTY SEVEN OKAY.
OKAY COME LIKE A DEATH NOT
FAIRLY [inaudible]
YEAH.
DOCTOR CHOI YEAH.
AB.
FOR SIXTY SEVEN OKAY HOLMAN
SUGGESTS -- HI [inaudible]
NO.
THE RECORD --
IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
THAT [inaudible]
YEAH -- YEAH
.
THIS IS -- THE
OR A MOVIE WE
NEED TO KEEP YOUR VOICE DOWN A
LITTLE BIT SO WE'RE TRYING -- TO
DO SOME OF THE OPEN UP SOME ROLE
PHONE THE MEMBERS.
TO MAKE UP.
CONSENT CALENDAR DEEP
[inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
I AB FOR SIXTY SEVEN BOEHNER
HOWEVER.
AB. FOR SIXTY SEVEN AM DEEP.
BY THE BY.
AB. TEN THIRTY TWO QUIRK DEEP
[inaudible]
HI I AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE
HOLDEN DEEP [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
I FULL OF YEAH.
IT WAS ON FOOD INSTANCE.
WITH THE RIVAL ON ON ON SEVEN
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVEN WELL WE THE SWING WAITING
OKAY.
OKAY I'D EVER GO BACK.
AGAIN YEAH -- YEAH
.
MISTER BROWN CODE IS HERE.
THE REAL LIFE LAST BILL FOR THE
DAY AB.
FIFTEEN A NINETY TWO MR BONTA
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES MY APOLOGIES -- TO
MAKE YOU WAIT THANK YOU FOR THE
TAX I APPRECIATE THEM -- TO
REMIND ME TO COME HERE -- AND
HAPPY TO BE WITH YOU.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT A BE FIFTEEN NINETY TWO
AND FOR THE WORK THAT YOU AND
YOUR STAFF HAVE PUT INTO THE
MEASURE.
I'M NOT JUST THIS YEAR BUT OVER
MANY YEARS THANK YOU.
AB FIFTY NINETY TWO WOULD
ESTABLISH LICENSURE REGULATIONS.
AND THE SUPERVISORY.
BOARD OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS UNDER
EXISTING LAW THE PROFESSION OF
ATHLETIC TRAINERS IS UNREGULATED.
IN FACT CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY THAT DOES
NOT REGULATE.
THE PROFESSION CURRENTLY SOMEONE
HAS NOT COMPLETED AN ATHLETIC
TRAINER EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM OR
PASSED THE NATIONAL
CERTIFICATION EXAM CAN STILL
CALL THEMSELVES.
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER THIS LACK OF
REGULATION PUT HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS COLLEGE STUDENTS
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES AND
THOUSANDS OF OTHER CALIFORNIANS
AT SEVERE.
RISK OF HARM ATHLETIC TRAINERS
ARE OFTEN RESPONSIBLE FOR
MANAGING SERIOUS MEDICAL
CONDITIONS SUCH AS CONCUSSIONS
AND HE DAHLE MRS AND SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST A MISTAKE FROM AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER.
COULD LEAD TO INJURY DISABILITY
AND EVEN DEATH -- IT'S EXTREMELY
UNFORTUNATE THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
NO REGULATION FOR ATHLETIC
TRAINERS AS THEY TEND TO THE
DOCKING NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS
AND ATHLETES AND THIS MEASURE IS
LONG OVERDUE.
OTHER FOR TO WORKING TOGETHER TO
FIND THE APPROPRIATE BALANCE
HERE OF SCOPE AND SUPERVISION
FOR ATHLETIC TRAINERS AND OTHERS
MORE WORK TO DO.
IN THOSE AREAS AND I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OF THE ANALYSIS SO
WE CAN FINALLY BRING -- THE
NECESSARY PROTECTIONS FOR
CONSUMERS ATHLETES AND STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE WITH ME HERE TODAY IS
MICHAEL CHOOSE ARE REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC TRAINERS
ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF --
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOUGHT SAID
MY NAME IS MIKE JUST SORRY
MEDILL CREDENTIALED ATHLETIC
TRAINERS PHYSICAL THERAPIST HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CA TA.
RECEIVE MY TIME TO HEATHER
KRAMER WHO'S A AN ATHLETIC
TRAINER WHO WORKS -- IN A
PHYSICAL THERAPY CLINIC AND DON
KESSLER WHO WORKS WITH -- THE
NAVY SEALS BUT I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
SCHOOL HAVE.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS DON KESSLER
ON I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
I AM MAY ATHLETIC TRAINER AT
WITH THE NAVY SEALS I'VE BEEN
THERE FOR NINE YEARS AND SAN
DIEGO -- PREVIOUS TO THAT I WAS
AT SAN DIEGO STATE IS A HEAD
ATHLETIC TRAINER AND I WAS ALSO
THE HEAD OFF A TRAIN AT RUTGERS
UNIVERSITY IN NEW JERSEY.
STERN AND THE NAVAL ACADEMY SO
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR QUITE
AWHILE FORTY SEVEN YEARS.
I I HELP -- SPONSOR BILL TRY TO
GET A BILL THROUGH -- IN NEW
JERSEY IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
AND WE SUCCEEDED AFTER SEVEN
YEARS OF GETTING IT THROUGH SO
I'M FAMILIAR WITH THIS AND KNOW
THAT.
AFTER THE TRAINING IS CHANGED A
LOT SINCE I'VE WORKED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN PART OF
IT IS THAT.
PEOPLE HAVE SEEN THE THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO TO TRY TO HELP AND
THIS STATE NOT HAVING AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER THAT IS
CERTIFIED IN MANY SITUATIONS --
CAN BE HARMFUL -- TO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE BEING
TREATED WHAT I WANT TO SHOW IS
THAT PRESENTLY HAVING SERVED IN
COLLEGES FOR A LONG PERIOD OF
TIME.
THAT I'M WORKING MORE OF A
CLINICAL SITUATION -- I'M AS
CIVIL SERVICE -- PERSON WORKING
FOR THE MILITARY AND IN THAT --
ROLE IT IS WORKING IN A CLINICAL
POSITION I DON'T GO OUT ON THE
FIELD AND AND TAKE CARE OF THE
AND INJURED SEALS IN THOSE
SITUATIONS WE HAVE HOSPITAL
CORPSMAN.
FOR BUT IN THE CLINICAL
SITUATION I TAKE CARE OF THEM
AND AND TO SHOW THAT I WORK WITH
THREE PHYSICAL THERAPIST AND WE
ALL WORK EQUALLY.
IN WHAT WE DO AND USE OUR
EXPERTISE TO TRY -- TO MAKE
THOSE INDIVIDUALS GO BACK INTO
THE ACTION THAT THEY HAVE TO DO
AND THE ACTION IS NOT ATHLETICS
AS SUCH IT CERTAINLY IS ATHLETIC
NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO DO SOME OF
THESE THINGS.
BUT THEY ARE TRULY WORK
EXPERIENCES THEY'RE DOING IN A
DIFFERENT ENVIRONMENT BUT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE BACKGROUND
THAT WE RECEIVE IN TREATING
ATHLETE'S INFORMATICS SITUATIONS.
RE HAVING THEM AND FUNCTIONALLY
BRING THEM BACK IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO TRY TO GET THE MOST
EXPERTISE WE CAN AND AGAIN IT'S
BEEN -- SHOWN THAT THEY AFFECT
TRAINERS MABEL TO DO THAT
RECENTLY THE MARINE CORPS HAS
PUT AN ATHLETIC TRAINER WITH
EACH OF THE BRIGADES.
AND DEBT IN SAN DIEGO THE SMART
CLINICS HAVE THREE ATHLETIC
TRAINERS. TO MOVE MORE MY
STUDENTS AND ONE WAS A FORMER
ASSISTANT OF MINE AND THERE ARE
THREE TRAINERS WITH A DIFFERENT
BRIGADES IN THEIR TRAINING SO
THEY OTHER AREAS HAVE SHOWN THAT
THE ATHLETE TRAINING CAN DO.
A LOT TO HELP SUPPORT AND IT'S
NOT JUST IN THE TRADITIONAL SIDE
OF BEING ON THE SIDE OF THE
FIELD WHICH I DID FOR THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS -- BUT IN THE
CLINICAL SIDE OF TRYING TO GET
PEOPLE ON BACK BETTER AND TRY TO
GET THEM BACK INTO WHATEVER THE
FUNCTIONS THAT THEY NEED TO DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
BUSINESSES IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME [inaudible]
FOR OPPOSITION.
YEAH -- I'M SORRY.
WHAT CARD?
ALONE LARA.
I AM IN SUPPORT MY NAME IS
HEATHER KRAMER AND I'M AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER WITH ELDORADO
PHYSICAL THERAPY.
AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
I'VE BEEN WORKING IN PHYSICAL
THERAPY FOR ALMOST SEVENTEEN
YEARS AND THE CLINIC THAT I'M
WITH NOW I'VE BEEN WITH FOR
FOURTEEN AND A HALF YEARS.
AND IT IS BEEN A GREAT PRIVILEGE
OF MINE TO WORK IN PHYSICAL
THERAPY AND WORK WITH A LOT OF
OTHER PROFESSIONALS WHETHER IT'S
PHYSICAL THERAPISTS OR PHYSICAL
THERAPY ASSISTANTS ANOTHER
ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
WE HAVE THREE CLINICS AND WE
HAVE FOURTEEN PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS SEVEN PHYSICAL
THERAPY ASSISTANTS AND FOR
ATHLETIC TRAINERS AND WE WORK IN
A VERY COLLABORATIVE.
TEAM APPROACH MY BOSS SINCE THEY
STARTED THE COMPANY TWENTY YEARS
AGO.
HE IMMEDIATELY SAW THE VALUE OF
HAVING ATHLETIC TRAINERS IN HIS
CLINICS TO HELP TREAT PATIENTS I
SEE PATIENTS FROM AGES THREE ALL
THE WAY UP TO NINETY NINE AND
I'M WORKING.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH PHYSICAL
THERAPISTS THEY SEE THAT WHAT I
BRING TO THE TABLE MY DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE MY DIFFERENT SKILL
SETS THE KNOWLEDGE THAT I GET IN
MY SCHOOLING IS SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT FROM WHAT THEY GET AND
I BRING.
A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE TO THE
TABLE AND SO WE WORK SIDE BY
SIDE TREATING ALL OF THESE
PATIENTS ON A DAILY BASIS I'M IN
THE CLINIC ALL DAY LONG TREATING
PATIENTS.
AND THEY'VE ALWAYS SEEN THE
VALUE OF HAVING ATHLETIC
TRAINERS THERE BECAUSE WE DO
MORE THAN JUST PROVIDE EXERCISES
AND STRETCHES AND TAPING.
WHERE THERE TO PROVIDE MANUAL
SKILLS TO HELP EVALUATE INJURIES
TO HELP DETERMINE THE NEXT STEP
OF WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN FOR
THOSE PATIENTS?
AND WE'RE NOT JUST SIMPLY PEOPLE
THEY'RE STANDING ON THE SIDELINE
HANDING OUT WATER AND TAPING
ANKLES THERE'S SO MUCH MORE I
HAVE A DOCTORATE IN ATHLETIC
TRAINING AND MY BOSS WAS VERY
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT ME IN THAT
ENDEAVOR. TO SEE ME BRING EVEN
MORE INTO OUR CLINIC AND BE ABLE
TO BRING BETTER PATIENT CARE TO
OUR PATIENTS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
JUST LOOKING AT THEM FROM A
PHYSICAL THERAPY STANDPOINT I'M
LOOKING AT THEM FROM A
BIOMECHANICAL STANDPOINT.
A FUNCTIONAL MOVEMENT STANDPOINT
IF THEY ARE ATHLETES WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO TO GET HIM BACK ON TO
THE FIELD OR THE COURT IF
THEY'RE GOING INTO A WORK
SITUATION WHAT WE LOOK AT BIO
MECHANICALLY HOW CAN THEY GO
BACK INTO.
THEIR MOVEMENTS THAT THEY NEED
FOR WORK IN THESE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT AS AN ATHLETIC TRAINER I
HAVE A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
THAT I BRING TO PHYSICAL THERAPY.
AND CAN WORK IN CONJUNCTION AND
VERY VERY WELL WITH ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES AS I SAID I'VE BEEN
THERE FOR OVER FOURTEEN YEARS
WITH THIS COMPANY.
AND IT'S BEEN A REALLY GREAT
BLESSING FOR ME SO I I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
KATHLEEN SORIANO WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE FOR THE UNIVERSITY THANK
YOU.
TERRY MCHALE WITH ERIN READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC TRAINERS
ASSOCIATION.
WE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE
SOMEONE BONTA CARRYING THE THE
BANNER THIS YEAR IN THE
WILLINGNESS OF THIS COMMITTEE TO
REVIEW.
CALIFORNIA PRIDES ITSELF ON HOW
ATHLETIC WE ARE HEALTH PHYSICAL
WE ARE HOW MUCH WE LOVE THE
OUTDOORS.
AND IT IS DISTRESSING THAT WE
ARE THE ONLY ONE OF FORTY NINE
OF FIFTY STATES FORTY NINE
OTHERS.
THAT HAVE DEALT MORE
PROGRESSIVELY WITH THIS ISSUE.
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MICHELLE MCCANN
WHAT ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
INTERSCHOLASTIC FEDERATION HIGH
SCHOOL ATHLETICS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GEN NATIONALIST ON BEHALF OF
JUDGE AT HIGH SCHOOL ATHLETICS
CARMICHAEL IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MICHAEL THE ASSISTANT ATHLETIC
TRAINER SECOND A STATE
UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU.
BAILEY DAVID ASSISTANT ATHLETIC
TRAINER AT SACRAMENTO STATE AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I BRANDED PIA DIRECTOR SPORTS
MEDICINE AND HEAD OUT THE
TRAINER SECTOR OF STATE WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE VARNUM WITH UC DAVIS
SPORTS MEDICINE AND FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TOM AB NOR SAN LEANDRO.
FORMER HEAD ATHLETIC TRAINER SAN
DIEGO STATE AND THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU YOU.
ANY OF WITNESSES THAT.
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME. FOR ONE
FROM A CABLE SPACE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SAID CARL
LUNDEN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION.
I JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT WITHOUT
THE ANALYSIS DID A TERRIFIC JOB
OF LAYING OUT THIS ISSUE ON BOTH
SIDES QUITE FRANKLY -- WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL WE THINK IT
IS OVERLY BROAD AS WRITTEN WE OF
GRAVE CONCERN OVER -- THE SCOPE
OF PRACTICE THIS LISTED IN THIS
BILL TODAY AS IT.
SETS WE ARE NOT AGAINST ATHLETIC
TRAINERS BEING RECOGNIZED IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE HELPED IN THE
PAST GET TWO BILLS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK.
DISPEL HOWEVER GOES A LONG WAY
AND FAR AFIELD.
FROM WHAT TRADITIONAL ATHLETIC
TRAINING HAS BEEN IN THE
EDUCATION TRAIN IT SUPPORTS IT.
AND I LIKE GAS SMOKE CHRIS
READER GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN WHO IS BOTH
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER IN A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST -- TO COMMENT
MORE THAT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT GO
AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITYTO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY.
MY NAME IS CHRIS RATE GOVERNOR
FAIRS COMMITTEE CHAIR OF
CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION.
I'M A CALIFORNIA LICENSE
PHYSICAL THERAPIST AND CERTIFIED
ATHLETIC TRAINER.
ARISES BEGIN OPPOSITION AB
FIFTEEN NINETY TWO THE PARTS OF
THIS BILL HAVE COMMUNITY ARGUED
THAT THERE ARE BAD ACTORS POSING
AS ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
AND WORKING IN CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOLS WHO ARE UNQUALIFIED.
THE RUINS OF ALSO CONVENIENTLY
USE THE ARGUMENT THAT ATHLETES
ARE SAFER WHEN A CERTIFIED
ATHLETIC TRAINERS ON THE
SIDELINES.
WE ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT HAVING
A QUALIFIED PROFESSIONAL THE
SIDELINES IS IMPORTANT TO THE
SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF OUR
ATHLETES HOWEVER THE LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
ATHLETES SPORTS SPORTS TEAMS.
OR SPORTS VENUES.
THE BILL TALK ABOUT AUTHOR
TRAINERS WORKING WITH PATIENTS
FOR TREATMENT.
IT CREATES A NEW BACHELOR'S
LEVEL HEALTHCARE PROVIDER WITH
THE FREEDOM TO WORK WITH ANY
PERSON FOR NEARLY ANY CONDITION
WITH ESSENTIALLY NO OVERSIGHT.
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS AGO
FOR LEGISLATORS STRUGGLED WITH
THE CONCEPT OF LICENSING
ATHLETIC TRAINERS FIGHTING
PROTECTION OF THE TITLE
CERTIFIED ATHLETIC TRAINER BY
ALLOWING ONLY THOSE WHO HAVE A
CERTIFICATION FROM THE BOARD
CERTIFICATION.
THE GOLD STANDARD PROSTHETIC
TRAIN PROFESSION WOULD ENSURE
THAT ONLY THOSE WITH THE
APPROPRIATE EDUCATION TRAINING
OR HOLD THEMSELVES OUT AS I
THINK THERE'S A CALIFORNIA.
THIS REASONABLE SOLUTION WAS
RECOMMENDED BY TWO THOUSAND FIVE
CALIFORNIA JOINT LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE REPORT ON AFFECT AND
REGULATIONS IS ONE BY.
WAS ONE PASSED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE ON THREE PRIOR
OCCASIONS AS ONE SUPPORTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA PHYSICAL THERAPY
ASSOCIATION ON EACH OF THOSE
OCCASIONS.
THE ACTIVITIES DEFINED AS
ASSISTING LICENSURE ARE CIRCULAR
NATURE STATING THAT THE PRICE
ABOUT THEIR TRAINING INCLUDES
THOSE THINGS THAT QUOTE FALL
WITHIN.
THE PRACTICE STANDARDS ABOUT OUR
TRAINING.
IN QUOTE IN MULTIPLE LOCATIONS.
THIS ALSO ADVOCATES THE
AUTHORITY OF DETERMINING WHAT
ACTIVITIES FALL WITHIN THE SCOPE
OF PRACTICE OF NOT THEIR TRAINER
SOLELY TO THE BOARD OF
CERTIFICATION.
AND OR THE COMMISSION ON THE
ACCREDITATION ABOUT A TRAINED
EDUCATION.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
THE DUTY TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT OF
A PROFESSION TO ENSURE PUBLIC
PROTECTION.
IT THEREFORE SHOULD BE THE SOLE
AUTHORITY IN DETERMINING WHAT
ACTIVITIES FALL WITH ANY
PROFESSIONS SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
ADDITIONALLY THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE CONTAIN AB FIFTEEN
NINETY TWO IS OVERLY BROAD IT
WOULD ALLOW AN ATHLETIC TRAINER
IN CALIFORNIA TO WORK WITH ANY
AND ALL CLIENTS.
IT DEFINES ATHLETIC ACTIVITY AS
QUOTE PARTICIPATION IN EXERCISE
SPORT GAME RECREATION WELLNESS
FITNESS PERFORMING ARTS OR
EMPLOYMENT ACTIVITIES THAT
REQUIRES PHYSICAL STRENGTH RANGE
OF MOTION FLEXIBILITY BODY
AWARENESS AND CONTROL.
SPEED STAMINA OR AGILITY WHICH
DESCRIBES ANY AND ALL ACTIVITY
PERFORMED BY ANY AND ALL PERSONS.
IT IS NOT SPECIFIC TO SPORT OR
ATHLETICS IN ANYWAY.
THIS BROAD DEFINITION PUT PUBLIC
SAFETY AT RISK BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
AUTHOR TRAINERS PROVIDE CARE TO
THE GENERAL POPULATION.
AND NO PRE PARTICIPATION SCREEN
REQUIRED.
INSTEAD OF THE POPULATION FOR
WHICH THEY ARE KNOWN TO TREAT
ATHLETES PARTICIPATING IN
ATHLETICS SETTINGS WITH A
PARTICLE TAYLOR TO AN INDIVIDUAL
ATHLETES SPECIFIC NEEDS.
FURTHER AB NINETY AFTER AB FIFTY
NAY TO CALL HER POSITION
OVERSIGHT AFFLECK TRAINER THAT
IS FAR MORE LENIENT THAN THAT OF
OTHER HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONS WHO
HAVE A GREATER LEVEL OF
EDUCATION AND TRAINING.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW ATHLETIC
TRAINER TO TREAT A PATIENT FOR
ANY INJURY OR ILLNESS OR NOT FOR
AN UNRESTRICTED AMOUNT OF TIME
WITHOUT THE PATIENT EVER HAPPEN
TO SEE A PHYSICIAN.
AS LONG AS A PHONE CALL BETWEEN
THE OTHER TRAINER POSITION HAS
OCCURRED AT SOME POINT TIME.
THE USE OF PATIENT IN THIS
CONTEXT CLEARLY PLACES THE
AUTHOR TRAINER OUTSIDE OF THE
SPORTS WORLD AND DELINEATES A
LEVEL POSITION OVERSIGHT THAT IS
VASTLY MORE LENIENT PROPER
TRAINERS.
WITH A BACHELOR'S LEVEL OF
EDUCATION.
THAN WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS AUTHORIZED FOR
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANTS OR
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST WITH A
MASTER'S DEGREE OR FOR A
PHYSICAL THERAPIST WITH A
DOCTOR'S DEGREE.
FINALLY WE ARE CURIOUS WHAT IS
THE VOID THAT THIS BILL IS
TRYING TO RESOLVE.
AB FIFTY NINETY TWO SIMPLY
CREATES A NEW LICENSE BACHELOR'S
LEVEL HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL
THERE'S AUTHORIZED TO TREAT
PATIENTS FOR NEARLY ANY INJURY
OR ILLNESS WITH ESSENTIALLY NO
OVERSIGHT BY A PHYSICIAN OR
OTHER APPROPRIATE LICENSE
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY SEVERAL
LICENSE HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
PHYSICAL THERAPIST PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANTS NURSES NURSE
PRACTITIONERS OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPISTS WHO ARE AUTHORIZED BY
THE STATE TO PROVIDE THE TYPE OF
CARE.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW DOCTORS
BEFORE.
IN EVERY CASE THE ATHLETIC
TRAINER HAS A LOWER EDUCATIONAL
STANDARD AND YET WOULD BE
AUTHORIZED HAVE A MUCH BROADER
SCOPE UNDER THIS BILL -- ONE
OTHER ONE OTHER COMMENT IS WHEN
AFTER TRYING TO WORK IN OTHER
SETTINGS LIKE PHYSICAL THERAPY
CLINICS.
THERE ARE WORKING UNDER THE
SUPERVISION THE DIRECT
SUPERVISION OF A PHYSICAL
THERAPIST THEY ARE NOT WORKING
AS AN ATHLETIC TRAINER USING
THEIR UNIQUE SKILL SETS AS A
FIVE TRAINERS THERE BEING
DIRECTED IN EVERYTHING THEY DO
BY THE SUPERVISING -- THAT
PROVIDER.
SO AS WITH PRIOR ATTEMPTS TO
LICENSURE.
ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
AS WITH PRIOR ATTEMPTS TO
LICENSE AFFLECK TRAINERS AB
FIFTY NINETY TWO IS YET ANOTHER
HIGHLY FLAWED BILL I STRONGLY
URGE THE MEMBERS THIS COMMITTEE
TO JOIN OPPOSITION.
I CAST A NO VOTE TODAY. ONE MORE
WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
CURTIS L<c.cyan>G JUNIOR WITH THE</c>
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND REGISTERED
NURSES IN CALIFORNIA -- WE ALIGN
WITH CARL LUNDEN AND CHRIS READ
HERE -- CNA OPPOSES THIS
LEGISLATION -- UNLESS AMENDED WE
LIKE TO SEE LANGUAGE ADOPTED --
CALLING FOR TITLE PROTECTION OF
CERTIFICATION INSTEAD.
A FOR CALIFORNIA ATHLETIC
TRAINERS CNA BELIEVES AND
PATIENT PROTECTION AND ADVOCACY
AND STRONGLY AGREES THAT
ATHLETES AND STUDENT ATHLETES
ARE SAFER WHEN THERE'S A
QUALIFIED.
HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONAL ON THE
SIDELINES DURING GAMES AND
PRACTICES.
HOWEVER THIS BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE PROVISIONS TO YOUR TO
DIRECTLY ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
INSTEAD AB FIFTEEN NINETY TO
CREATE A NEW LICENSE HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL WITH THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE THAT IS NOT WELL
DEFINED AND EXTENDS BEYOND THE
SETTING IN WHICH ATHLETIC
TRAINERS.
CURRENTLY PRACTICE.
AND IT'S NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING OF
ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
NOW BELIEVE THAT -- I CONCUR
THAT THE ANALYSIS MISMATCHES
ANALYSIS REFLECTS THIS OVERLY --
BROAD NATURE AND SUPERVISION
WITH IN THIS BILL.
CURRENTLY ATHLETIC TRAINERS
PRIMARILY WORK WITH ATHLETES IN
ATHLETIC SETTING SUCH AS A
SPORTS TEAM UNIVERSITY IT CETERA.
IS NOT CLEAR HOW THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS AS
OUTLINED IN THE CURRENT BILL.
WOULD DIFFER FROM THE PHYSICAL
THERAPIST OR OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPIST -- PROFESSIONALS WERE
LICENSE TO TREAT ACTIVE
INDIVIDUALS IN ANY SETTING.
COUPLED WITH THE LATER --
SECTION OF THE BILL DEFINING THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE POSITION.
AN ALLOWANCE FOR TREATMENT BY AN
ATHLETIC TRAINER THE SCOPE OF
THE ATHLETIC TRAINERS UNDER AB.
FIFTEEN TWO WOULD ALLOW
TREATMENT OF PERSONS WITH THE
RANGE OF MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
PROPONENTS ALSO CLAIM THAT AFTER
THE TRAINERS WORK IN A VARIETY
OF SETTINGS WHICH IS TRUE.
BUT WHAT THEY FAILED TO MENTION
IS THAT THEY WORK IN THESE
SETTINGS NOT AS ATHLETIC
TRAINERS.
AS CHRIS MENTIONED HERE BUT IN
OTHER CAPACITY SUCH AS MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE PHYSICAL THERAPY AIDS
AND OTHER ROLES -- THE
SUPERVISION AN ATHLETIC TRAINER
AS OUTLINED IN THIS BILL IS NOT
SUFFICIENT.
AB FIFTY NINETY TWO ALLOWS
ATHLETIC TRAINERS TO FOLLOW
WRITTEN OR VERBAL PORTAL CALLS
ESTABLISHED BY POSITION WHO NEED
NOT BE PRESENT.
WHILE THIS MAY BE THE CURRENT
PRACTICE OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS IN
THE ATHLETIC SETTING WORKING
WITH ATHLETES EXTENDING THIS
LEVEL OF SUPERVISION. TO PERSONS
OUTSIDE OF ATHLETIC SETTING IS
HIGHLY PROBLEMATIC FOR US.
THE CONDITIONS OF THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE AND PERMIT THE ATHLETIC
TRAINER INTO ALSO ASSESS AND
EVALUATE AND ATHLETES CONDITION
THEN OFFER TREATMENT.
WORKING BY DIRECTION OF A
PROTOCOL WHEN NO POSITION AS
PRESIDENT WILL EFFECTIVELY
REQUIRE THE ATHLETE TRAINED TO
DIAGNOSE AN INDIVIDUAL'S
CONDITION TO CORRECTLY APPLIED
THE CORRECT TREATMENT PROTOCOL.
THE BILL YOU TO DIAGNOSE AS WELL
OUTSIDE THE SCOPE AND TRAIN OF
AN ATHLETIC.
TRAINER -- AND THEN WHAT ANOTHER
POINT AND LASTLY IS EVEN THE
CURRENT WORK FIRST WORKFORCE.
OF ATHLETIC TRAINERS WILL HAVE
TO BE RETRAINED AND WON'T COMPLY
WITH THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
IS SIGNED INTO LAW.
MANY ATHLETIC TRAINERS OBTAINED
THEIR CERTIFICATIONS WHEN --
WORKING ON INTERNSHIPS OR O. J.
T. OR ON THE JOB TRAINING --
WHICH WAS THE STANDARD FOR
ACHIEVING CERT CERTIFIED
ATHLETIC TRAINERS WHO HAVE
OBTAINED THEIR CERTIFICATE BY
THIS METHOD SELECT THE FORMAL
TRAINING VIA PROFESSIONAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM AS OUTLINED IN
THE BILL. FOR ALL THE ABOVE
REASONS CNA IS OPPOSED TO AB
FIFTY NINE TWO IN ITS CURRENT
FORM.
ACCORDINGLY RESPECT THE WE ASK
FOR YOU KNOW VOTE ON A. B. EIGHT
TWENTY TWO UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME IS AN
AFFILIATION MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
IVAN ALL TOMORROW WITH CAPITAL
ADVOCACY I'M HERE ON BEHALF THE
OCCUPATIONAL THERAPY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE AMERICAN OCCUPATIONAL
THERAPY ASSOCIATION WE'RE IN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
FOR THE REASONS STATED BY MY
COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU.
A MISTER SHARON MEMBERS PAT
WHALEN ELSE WILL SNACK SEE HERE
ON BEHALF OF UNIACKE -- ONE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFFER VERY THOROUGH
AND BALANCED -- ANALYSIS AND
ALSO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HIS
COMMENTS BOTH IN THE ANALYSIS
AND AT THE AT THE BEGINNING OR A
CITY PEOPLE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS REPEAT PROJECT THAT.
THANK YOU.
JANE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION --
ANY QUESTION FROM THE DAIS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN NOT A
QUESTION BUT A COMMENT I TELL
THIS BILL -- LAST YEAR I BELIEVE --
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BUT I DO HOPE THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO SEE IF THERE'S A
WAY OF ADDRESSING THEIR CONCERNS
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS I ALSO
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH SO.
HOPEFULLY YOU CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE SAID IT BEST THAN OF I
QUITE HONESTLY FIND IT AWKWARD
WHEN I SEE SUCH A WONDERFUL
CHAMPION OF LABOR AND OF THE
NURSES.
RUNNING IN CONTRAST WITH AN
ISSUE THAT I KNOW HE CARES VERY
DEEPLY ABOUT SO I I I SUSPECT
THAT THERE'S A HAPPY MEDIUM HERE.
THAT COULD BE STRUCK SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING IT TODAY
AND ENCOURAGE CONTINUED DIALOGUE
AND AND A POTENTIAL HAPPY MEDIUM
THANK YOU -- I WILL OKAY --
MEMBER CAN KAMLAGER-DOVE.
THANK YOU WILK I WAS JUST
WONDERING -- I'VE.
BEEN TOLD THAT THIS.
HAS COME BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
MULTIPLE TIMES -- IT'S PROBABLY
AN ADOLESCENT BY NOW BUT I WAS
WONDERING WAS THE BONTA IF YOU
AND THE FOLKS SUPPORTING THIS
BILL WOULD BE WILLING TO RESPOND
TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS STATED
BY THE OPPOSITION BECAUSE THE
ANALYSIS.
I THINK WAS VERY GOOD AND I TO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
SCOPE OF PRACTICE AND MOST OF
THE COMMENTS THAT WERE SHARED BY
THOSE THAT WERE -- IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL ACTUALLY TALKED ABOUT
OFFERING COLLABORATIVE CARE --
AND WORKING IN CONJUNCTION WITH
OTHER QUALIFIED PROFESSIONALS
PROBABLY SO THAT EVERYONE IS
STAYING IN THEIR LANE IN
OFFERING THE BEST CARE POSSIBLE --
FOR THE PATIENTS OR THOSE
RECEIVING -- YOU KNOW THEY'RE
CARE SO CAN I WOULD.
JUST LIKE TO KNOW IF YOU WERE
WILLING TO RESPOND OR IF YOU
WANTED TO RESPOND IN YOUR
CLOTHES I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU
WOULD PREFER.
I AN DO EITHER BUT PASSED MY
CLOTHES WOULD BE BEST.
AS A MINIMUM BONTA A HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS.
YOUR BILL IS -- IN ESSENCE OF
TRYING -- TO A CREATE.
TO THE LICENSED -- AND THE
REGULATIONS REGARDING -- TO
ATHLETIC TRAINERS.
SO TO GET THE TITLE.
AS A MATTER OF A GLADIATOR
TRAINER -- BY THE MORAL LAW.
I THREADED TRAINING BESTSELLERS
NEW ENTITY YOU HAVE TO CREATE.
BUT THE I WAS CURIOUS SO WHY NOT
GO UP -- WHEN NOT TESTIFY YEAR?
MENTIONED THAT I'M A CERT.
THE LEVY TRAINER.
THERE'S NO SUCH A THING ARE IN
CALIFORNIA SO FAR ALL RIGHT.
NO CERTIFIED BUT SOMEBODY
MENTIONED I'M CERTIFIED.
THERE'S A NATIONAL CERTIFICATION
NATIONAL CERTIFICATION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SO YOU USING OUR THAT THE
NATIONAL STAND THE STATE
CERTIFIED NOT BY CALIFORNIA. TO
BUY OUT CREATING THIS -- NAM
BORDER WALL.
A NEW ATHLETIC.
TRAINING PROGRAM HOW WILL IT THE
EMPLOYEE -- THE TRAINERS
QUALIFICATIONS TO WHAT ACTUAR
SERVICE -- TO THE TREE A THE
ATHLETICS.
AT ATHLETES SO AT THIS TIME --
BECAUSE A WHAT I GATHER FROM
LISTENING WITH SIZES THAT THE
EVEN THE DOCTORS AND THE NURSES
SO KEEP OCCUPATIONAL THERAPIST
SO.
WHO NEED TO HELP THE INJURED THE
ATHLETE'S CELL ON THE SIDELINE?
THEY ARE UNDER THE CATEGORY --
FOR BROAD A TERM I FLATTENING
TRAINERS.
AREN'T THEY USE AS SOUTH MANY.
A DREADED TRAINERS.
SO -- EXCEL SO DID.
THIS BILL HOW WILL IT TO UNIFY.
ARE THOSE PEOPLE FIELD.
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO BECOME
ATHLETIC TRAINERS SO.
WAR WAR ARE THE ONES TO TRAINING
TO MEAD COMMONSENSE HIS THAT
APPLY TO YOUR TRAINING IS SO.
HOW TO PLAY BETTER CAN IT NOT
NOT THE MEDICAL STE A SUPPORT
TEAM OKAY?
SO IT IS A KIND OF VERY VAGUE OF
WHAT DISABILITY RANKED
ACCOMPLISH.
AND WHAT BENEFITS THAT WOULD PUT
A BRING ACTUALLY TO THE FEAR THE
AND AFTER THESE.
MR BONTA COULD YOU PRETTY PLEASE
AND TO FURTHER THAN TO DO DURING
YOUR CLOTHES YES I HAVE TO
EXCUSE MYSELF A LITTLE BIT BUT I
JUST WANTED TO STATE -- DAD OF
ICE.
HOW THE AYE RECOMMENDATION
BECAUSE I FELT THIS IS ABOUT
TIME?
THAT WE ESTABLISH A FRAMEWORK
FOR TO LICENSING AS SLICK --
UNDER THE TRAINERS I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF DETAIL AND I
NEED TO BE IRONED OUT AND THIS
BILL WOULD BE REFERRED TO THE
COMING HERE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS.
EMMA HOPING THAT -- WOULD
DIRECTORS OF OUR MEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR NOTED THAT
THE DETAIL.
AND GO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH US AND AND AND
GETTING SOME OF MEMON INTO YOUR
BILL.
SO IT WAS SHOT ON GOING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AND
AND AND THANK YOU MISTER CHOI
FOR FOR YOUR QUESTIONS.
LET ME TOUCH.
ME TRY TAKE A STAB AT IT STE --
TRY TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
RIGHT NOW THE ATHLETIC TRAINING
PROFESSION IS UNREGULATED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA UNIQUELY SO
THE ONLY STATE IN THE ENTIRE
NATION THAT DOES NOT -- REGULATE
OUR ATHLETIC TRAINING PROFESSION
IT IT NEEDS TO BE REGULATED.
I THINK MOST FOLKS WOULD AGREE
WITH THAT I THINK THE THAT THE
BAIT IS LARGELY AROUND SCOPE.
OF PRACTICE AND AND SUPERVISION --
SO THIS WOULD CREATE A LICENSURE
PROGRAM -- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY WOULD BE
OF A BOARD ABOUT THAT OUR
TRAINERS THAT SUPERVISES WHERE
THEY'LL BE REGULATIONS OVER
QUALITY REQUIREMENTS RIGHT NOW
ANYONE CAN HOLD HIMSELF OUT AS
AN ATHLETIC TRAINER WHETHER THEY
HAVE A CERTIFICATION OR NOT
WHETHER THEY HAVE EDUCATION AND
ATHLETIC TRAINING OR NOT.
THAT'S NOT OKAY TO BE NOTHING
BETWEEN -- TO HAVE THAT TITLE
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE -- TO BE ABLE
TO DELIVER A CERTAIN QUALITY OF
CARE AND SUPPORT AND SERVICES SO
THAT TO THIS BILLS SIX TO DO AND
AND TO THE THE QUESTION FROM --
MISS KAMAGRA OF I'M LISTENING TO
THE THE POINTS AND IN THE POINT
ABOUT DIAGNOSIS AND EMPLOYMENT
ACTIVITIES AND SCOPE OF PRACTICE
AND SUPERVISION.
THAT THEIR GOOD POINTS THAT
REASONABLE PEOPLE CAN --
DISAGREE ARE PERHAPS BUT ALSO
CAN FIND COMMON GROUND ON AND
AND DIALOGUE IS DESIRED AND
NEEDED. TO GET TO WHERE WE NEED
TO BE.
AND SO ESOS LISTENING SO I'M
LISTENING AND I'M AND AND I WANT
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS THIS ISSUE IT WAS
EASY BE SELF BY NOW.
AND IT HASN'T AND SO IT REQUIRES
US COMING TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY
AND AN AREA OF COMMON GROUND
WHERE WE CAN GET.
REGULATIONS THAT ARE NEEDED FOR
ATHLETIC TRAINER FOR THE FIRST
TIME THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
A WAY THAT IS CONSISTENT WITH
APPROPRIATE SCOPE OF PRACTICE
AND ALSO SUPERVISION.
I'VE ALWAYS BELIEVED YOU KNOW
THE SCHOOL PRACTICES CAN BE
DIFFICULT I KNOW THAT EACH THE
PRACTICING GROUP SEES IT.
MAYBE A DIFFERENT WAY THAN
OTHERS BUT MY GOAL IS ALWAYS TO
HAVE -- HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
PROVIDE THEIR CARE WITHIN THEIR
DISCOVER THE TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE AND NOT BE ON IT.
THAT'S GOOD FOR PATIENTS IT'S
GOOD -- FOR IT IS A GOOD WAY TO
PRACTICE IS GOOD FOR A
REGULATORY REGIMES SO.
OB WE NOTICED MORE WORK TO DO
WE'RE COMMITTED TO DOING THAT
WORK -- IF WE'RE ABLE TO GET OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE TODAY -- I
COMMIT TO CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE
TO IN THE WORK WORKING WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS LISTENING TO THE
CONCERNS EMBRACE TODAY DOING MY
BEST TO ADDRESS THEM.
I THINK YOU ARE VERY MUCH A
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OUT CAN I
FOLLOW UP ON THE QUESTION. ONE
THE DEFINITION ALMOST OF
LICENSURE PROGRAM IS TO SET UP
ALL.
ON THOUGH THAT THE BROAD TERM
NOT AMONG -- ATHLETIC TRAINER
AND KNOW WHO WILL BE LISTED
UNDER THAT -- TERMINOLOGY --
BLOOD.
IT WAS WHAT WE HAVE SOME
DEFINITIONS -- IN THE BILL BOTH
ATHLETIC TRAINING AND FOR
ATHLETIC ACTIVITY AND I THINK
THAT'S WHERE SOME OF THE DEBATE
IS IS OCCURRING RIGHTFULLY AND
IN TERMS OF WHAT OTHER BRIGHT
DEFINITIONAL MEETS IN BOUNDS AND
BOUNDARIES.
OF OF WHO WILL BE INCLUDED IN
AND WHO WILL NOT SO YEAH I THINK
YOU'RE ASKING APPROPRIATE
QUESTION AND AT BUT IT'S A
QUESTION THAT CONTINUES TO BE AN
OPEN WHEN WE HAVE A STARTING
POINT WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE SET
FORTH OUR DEFINITIONS.
IN THIS BILL FOR FOR ALL TO SEE
AND REVIEW AND WE WE WE HAVE
SOME CRITICISM TODAY WHICH I
THINK IS FAIR FOR EXAMPLE IN
UTAH THIS COUNTRY THERE ARE JUST
A WOULD BE -- POTENTIALLY CATHER
WHERE ISIS A TRAIN OR NOW NO NOT
AT ALL.
I MEAN THE BILL SPECIFIC AND
SAYS THAT THE PRACTICE OF
ATHLETIC TRAINING DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY OF THE FOLLOWING I'M
SORRY IF I CAN INTERRUPT MISTER
CHAIR I THINK THAT WAS THE THE
WITNESS THE MEMBER AUTHORS CLOSE
THAT WAS MY CLOTHES ALTHOUGH I
THINK.
YES.
I THINK IT'S A TIME.
FOR OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
MEMBERS OF OUR OR NO FOOT YEAH
RURAL COREY.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE THE CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AB. FIFTEEN NINETY TWO ONE
THIRTY PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS.
KANSEN CHU.
DEEP.
NO.
NO DAVID CHIU.
DAVID CHIU AYE CHOI.
I HAVEN'T RECEIVED ALL THE
ANSWERS YES SO PHENOMENAL.
CHU I KNOW FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
I KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE I MISS ARIAN
[inaudible]
NAZARIAN HI -- WILL PUT THIS ON
HOLD [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
PROTOCOL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF --
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
READING OF LET'S GO [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK CALENDAR DAVID CHIU HI
DAVID CHIU ONLINE.
AB.
FOR SIXTY SEVEN DAVID CHIU HI
DAVID CHIU I YEAH.
AB TEN THIRTY TWO QUIRK DAVID
CHIU HI DAVID CHIU ONLINE.
AB FIFTEEN NINETY THREE HOLDEN
DAVID CHIU HI DAVID CHIU ONLINE.
AB FIFTEEN NINETY TWO BONTA.
DAVID CHIU I THINK I JUST BY.
AND THEN NO.
WAS A CONSENT ITEM THE LAST ONE
RAMIS ITEM.
GREAT OKAY.
LEAVE A THE ROLE OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO COME BACK
.
SO I NEED TO MAKE UP -- FOR
PARTICULAR BOTH ON AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY TWO OKAY SO I
JUST NEED TO MAKE UP. FOR A. B.
ADD ON TO IT A AB FIFTEEN NINETY
TWO KANSEN CHU HI KANSEN CHU
<c.cyan>WI.</c>
ALL RIGHT.
HEARING THIS DORM [inaudible]
THANK YOU